Rebecca darjew to ride the Metro into
London
I was like come on let's go oh it was
you daring her no I said let's just go
we're gonna go right now right I was
like come on let's go was it were you
guys like filming and it was like no we
were working uh I think it was on Rogue
Nation we were working and there's bad
traffic
so I was like let's just go to the metro
and just go in I just put my hat on you
know my headphones and right there's no
one's there and no one picked you out it
was wonderful you know people on the on
the Metro they're all reading their
stuff and they want to be in their own
world so I just get on we're there like
this and I remember I was I stood up at
the pole
there's like 14 year old kid this girl
was there and everyone was looking at
their phones and she just she's just
looking at me
like this and then she just goes and she
just looks at everyone on the train like
that and then she just goes back and
looked over and kind of kind of my heads
down I got my baseball cap and she's
just staring at me like this I said I
just went
took her iPhone and went click and was
like